neuvième jour de mouvement de
protestation des policiers se sont
rassemblés aujourd'hui devant tous les
palais de justice de france et notamment
celui de versailles et où ils étaient
une quarantaine
ils réclament entre autres la révision
des règles de légitime défense
notre journaliste nicolas kirillovitch
interviewé match à ce gaillard
secrétaire départemental du syndicat
unsa
le rassemblement d'aujourd'hui c'est
pour que il une conscience qu'ils soient
prises au niveau du pouvoir judiciaire
nous demandons une application plus
ferme des lois et des peines qui
concourent les individus qui seraient
auteurs de violences à l'encontre des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique comme les policiers quand des
peines sont prononcés à l'encontre
d'auteurs de violences contre les
policiers
nous estimons que les peines sont trop
faibles pour que ce soit significatif et
empêcher les récidives il faut que ce
soit des peines qu'ils puissent être
dissuasive